all right in the collector world of
Classics usually old pieces of tech
aren't really all that interesting like
who wants to buy an iPhone 6 right now
the number one most sought after piece
of tech in The Collector world is the
factory sealed unopened original iPhone
now fun fact back when we went to go
make that uh reviewing every single
iPhone video we did have to go back and
find and buy a working version of every
single iPhone ever made and the further
back you go the harder it is to find a
working version and we eventually did
find a couple like these three original
used but still working iPhones from
2007. maybe it's because they're 16
years old they are really beat up but
the fact that they're still working is
kind of a miracle finding one that is
original still sealed never been opened
never even been touched by human hands
or seen by human eyes is extremely rare
it's so rare that I've actually seen
many people get scammed by this an
unopened iPhone is so rare and valuable
that people will actually seal a used
original iPhone and sell it online as an
original and man YouTubers have fallen
victim to this spending thousands of
dollars to try to get their hands on
what they thought was going to be an
untouched iPhone it's just crazy that
people go out scamming like this but hey
the difference in value between just any
old original iPhone and a new sealed
untouched iPhone is gigantic and it's
well worth the price of the cellophane
and the heat gun and the effort required
to make an old iPhone seem new only
about 6 million first gen iPhones were
ever sold and so of course the number of
unopened ones will only ever go down
from here and it's sort of this weird
game of trying to figure out when their
value has peaked and looking at the
numbers it actually feels like it has
peaked so one actually sold at an
auction in February this year for over
sixty thousand dollars which was a
record and the highest we've ever seen
then another one appeared at an auction
in March a month later that one went for
fifty five thousand dollars then there
was one with this lucky you sticker even
more rare they probably thought they
were going to get the most money for it
but it actually went up at an auction a
few weeks ago in Chicago and somebody
scooped it for only forty thousand
dollars I guess they got a bit of a
discount because that person
was me
and this
is the package it came in uh because
that auction house was not messing
around it was actually kind of surreal
winning this auction just for the record
it's not like a normal auction site like
ebay.com where you just click a button
and you win this is an actual auction
like a live streamed video of a guy with
a gavel going to get 6000 over here 6500
in the front row we got 6 800 on the
phone until we hear seven thousand seven
thousand here and it just keeps going
and you can participate from anywhere in
the world so they were going through a
bunch of stuff and the iPhone was item
number 203 and so when they got to 203 I
logged into the site and I had my
initial offer placed which was the
minimum of 32 000 the contents have been
x-rayed verified going once
going twice
sold to the online bidder moving on I
just won like that was the moment when I
committed to uh figuring this whole
thing out and so the rest of the price
was just uh sales tax and uh bidding
premium and shipping which feels like a
really good time to say that this video
is sponsored by
you there's a lot of things that we
could have spent forty thousand dollars
on like camera equipment for example but
we decided to do this and so we've
brought back the MKBHD matte black
wallet it was super limited edition
before but they were very popular so
we're bringing them back in a slightly
less limited edition at shop.mkbhd.com
they're also really sick and now I can
say that this video is made possible by
my wallet the link is below please buy
one
have I made a huge mistake
only one way to find out but uh it's
time to dig into this gigantic crate
[Music]
so my biggest question as I get into
this is how do I verify if this is
actually brand new and Untouched by
human hands like on the auction website
we did see that there were uh there were
some X-rays and the x-rays are cool and
they make it feel really official but
all we really know by seeing those
x-rays is that the accessories are in
fact in the Box we don't know if they're
untouched
oh and then the other thing about this
is when you when you put in a serial
number on like Apple's Checker uh you
can see that it is not registered so
whoever got this phone originally which
I think they said the name of the
original owner who brought it in uh
never registered it it was never used it
was never activated but that doesn't
mean it was never opened so this this is
very much uh a trust exercise
so many layers this is like a Russian
doll of
OG Tech products now this is the one
where I need to be careful I'm a
professional guys it's fine this is fine
there it is
that is the packaging
of this brand new
but also not so brand new
original iPhone you can see it's got a
little bit of Browning around it I'm not
too put off by that
and some of the articles that I read
online after I bought it were saying
basically this break here in the corner
and uh some other factors are possibly
why it went a little bit lower than the
record sixty thousand dollar price it
also has this upside down lucky you
sticker every article that I've read
that I've looked up about this lucky you
sticker nobody seems to know what it is
it's kind of confusing because it is
super rare other original sealed iPhones
don't have this sticker I even asked
people at Apple they don't know what it
means there are so many things I think
people forgot about the original iPhone
one is it didn't have an App Store so it
was just the apps that were on it and
two you couldn't set a wallpaper with
the first version of iOS so everyone's
iPhone looked exactly the same so
without any further ado
all right
this is the moment that all the value
just went from
forty thousand to uh
I don't know depends on how good the
condition of the phone is but the
plastic wrap this 16 year old
it it does have a smell
oh fancy so they had foam in the top of
the boxes and this is the way it showed
up facing you on the top
wow I think that is actually
brand new
just a little thing just a nicely
designed
little Factory seal thing oh this is
harder than a this happened in Justine's
video this is a hard screen protector to
take off
okay so there's a little piece of
plastic
hard plastic actually
then there is the documents signed
designed by Apple in California I
actually don't know if there's a sticker
this is now all new territory for me
despite it being old oh there's more
there's a there's a whole microfiber
inside that says iPhone on it
interesting
fingertips these are all the uh
the tips for using and operating your
iPhone in 2007 how to set a passcode how
to send a message how to browse the web
and uh oh
the stickers are a little bit Askew is
that how they were can you see those how
they're one of them is upside down and
tilted the other one's right side up and
tilted so it kind of it kind of looks on
purpose but also looks different because
they're usually aligned now there is
even more this is what I was talking
about this is what was x-rayed by the
auction house just to verify that
they're here but they're all also still
sealed in the box so USB a wall brick
you also have a 30 pin dock with a
headphone jack out on the back this is
nice let's open those let's open the
dock
[Music]
that is brand new wow
it would look like that uh you also get
two more things you get a 30 pin USB a
to 30 pin charging cable and data cable
you plug this into iTunes plug it into
your computer and earpods this was back
in the iconic days of well the
silhouette commercials and the white
headphones and plugging the wire into
your phone that feels very legit I don't
think it's going to turn on but I'm
gonna hold the power button anyway this
is one of those things where like it's a
16 year old battery of course it's not
going to turn on that would be a pretty
red flag actually if it did boot up if
it okay it doesn't that's good is this
this all just feels like exactly what
they didn't want me to do when I bought
this original iphone look at the
difference between
that brand new
fresh piece of metal
versus one that somebody was out using
in their everyday lives so while I wait
for this a little bit to just probably
take a minute to charge but I feel like
I can say that with all that I know and
all the research that I've done going
into this purchase it seems like this
one is legitimately brand new and
unopened if anyone can tell me if anyone
knows or if anyone who's watching this
worked in Apple retail around the time
in 2007 when the iPhone was launched
what if this came from Apple or if this
is something completely different I
would love to know because that would be
really interesting there's one story
online about how it might have been like
a holiday season sticker
who knows all right we're back actually
I'm back the next day hence the
different shirt and the haircut but
ignore that uh and I want to go over
everything that I learned because we now
have gotten the iPhone to turn on and I
am convinced that it is an unopened
original and I also learned some things
about the iPhone 2. so first of all I am
convinced that it's an unopened original
because of this shrink wrap being super
old because of the shrink wrap that was
around the iPhone that was inside the
Box being perfect looking and even the
fact that it's actually surprisingly
difficult to get a 1.0 iPhone to get
past this uh iTunes boot screen if you
actually download an old version of
iTunes and plug it in and try to
activate it you can get surprisingly far
and still not actually get it to
activate that all sort of lens Credence
to the fact that we could get other
iPhones to activate because they had
later versions of software long story
short this is as far as we got with it
and it does turn on and work the weird
thing that we found was number one
this is the original brick and the
original cable that came with the iPhone
we plugged them in overnight we came
back in the morning and it still didn't
turn on but when we replaced the brick
and not the cable
it actually started to charge second
thing to learn is there was no SIM card
ejector tool with the iPhone at all but
when you do grab a SIM card injector
tool and pop open the SIM card tray at
the top you will find that there is a
gigantic SIM card included with the
iPhone so this was a at T slash singular
exclusive when it came out and look at
the size of this SIM card this is the uh
the original size SIM card back in the
day before micro and nano SIM cards but
then yeah I did not remember that it
shipped with this dock until I did my
research and I also didn't know it would
ship with a black microfiber and these
Apple stickers that are slightly Askew
and this brand new pristine iPhone is
now worth dramatically less than what I
paid for it and that's okay so that'll
be it hopefully I don't regret this
thank you so much for watching and again
if anyone knows what the lucky you
sticker means definitely hit us up in
the comments or on Twitter
talk to you guys in the next one peace
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]